this is the steve young you most likely
remember he was a defining athlete of
his generation building a career out of
defying expectations
from being eighth on the byu depth chart
to a record usfl contract to sitting
behind the great joe montana for years
young ultimately became a hall of fame
super bowl winning quarterback
known for his pinpoint passing accuracy
and a penchant for dynamic runs trouble
he's going to be sacked no gets away he
runs gets away again to the 35 to the 20
that's 15 the 10 he died touchdown 49ers
i played 18 seasons there's a few that
have played more tom brady's now 23 but
i got as many as maybe anyone who ever
played and i still did have half of my
life that i wanted to be productive and
what could you do with another half of a
life
turns out a lot steve young didn't just
make a name and a fortune from his nfl
days armed with a law degree earned
while he was still a player and a
front-row seat to the tech revolution in
silicon valley he's quietly built an
investment firm that stunned more than
50 billion dollars in deals over the
past two decades i mean i look i i my
previous life it was amazing you know
throwing jerry rice a touchdown or brent
jones in front of 80 000 people and
winning games like there's nothing like
it
it's not 80 000 people watching it but
it feels familiar
i think that's why there is
magic in private equity
this is the steve young many haven't
seen the player turned investor i
recently got to spend a few days trying
to keep up with young from his offices
in silicon valley to a scottsdale golf
club and lots of places in between
what started as a straightforward story
about an athlete's successful transition
to business
turned out to be something much more
a tale of a relentless guy intent on
finally marrying his playing and
investing careers
with an eye toward radically changing
both deal making and athletes lives in
the process
hi
this is a tough decision um but i know
that i've made the right one and i
really feel it in my heart and i i can't
deny it
and so i retire from the great game of
football today
lots of players have managed to move
from the locker room to the board room
taking largely titular roles as advisors
and rain makers to companies or
investment firms few can say they've
committed as much as steve young
studying investment memos the same way
he studied the niners playbook
all right dental pat
you're on your horse
young's firm hggc sits in one of the
most fascinating corners of wall street
private equity once upon a time that
industry was relatively hidden
now it's one of the most influential
engines of the global economy it feels
like anecdotally i'm hearing more like
oh private equity consolidated this
practice
talking about acquiring dental practices
may not be as captivating as throwing
game-winning touchdowns but it's a
fast-growing very lucrative business
collectively private equity firms
control more than six trillion dollars
in assets according to mckinsey
the founders of the biggest firms guys
like henry kravis and steve schwartzman
they are billionaires many times over
so let's talk for a minute about the
basics of private equity
think of it like buying and selling
houses basically pe firms use a mix of
cash from investors and money borrowed
from banks to buy companies make them
more profitable and sell them down the
line and just like with houses some
people own them for a few years take
really good care of them and sell them
for a nice profit
others they're more like flippers who
look to do the minimum to make a quick
buck buyout ferns have been rightly
criticized over the years for shuttering
plants and cutting jobs in pursuit of
those massive profits
especially in recent years when it comes
to medical practices owned by private
equity firms
some practitioners have complained that
it forces them to choose between profits
and patients
so as they've grown in stature so too
has the scrutiny and the sense of
responsibility beyond the bottom line
young and his partners they're more than
cognizant of that historical reputation
and they're aiming to be more nurturing
than swashbuckling they're operating at
a smaller scale than the big firms in
the so-called middle market eyeing
companies worth 50 million dollars to
500 million dollars that's still a
pretty big business
hggc they've raised four funds totaling
almost seven billion dollars
for steve young it's unquestionably one
of the most successful second acts of
any former athlete
and while steve may live in the same
neighborhood in silicon valley as mark
zuckerberg you might not know it from
his ride
vans are the best cars on the road if
you don't have a van and you have kids
and you don't have a van you're an idiot
yeah
i mean how do you not go 14 cup holders
and six outlets i can run everything
right here is like a like a rocket ship
[Music]
87 was when i lived here i moved here
for the first time silicon valley was
kind of up to full speed in 10 years so
about 1997 yeah so in the last 20 years
or so 25 years even it's changed in that
the
biggest companies in the world yeah that
weren't here 20 years ago are now here
right but what hasn't changed is
stanford's down the street silicon
valley has always been kind of a
entrepreneurial place
back when steve was playing in the early
90s the technology boom was really just
cranking up just a few miles from where
the 49ers played at candlestick park
we're watching silicon valley just
explode around us in santa clara 3-com
cisco name any business any big business
and i don't know who had the first idea
i can't give it to anybody because i
know who said it was like let's let's
bring him in the locker room
and we'll tell him look we'll trade with
some access to the locker room because
that's what we have right because
everyone wanted that right the 49ers at
that time it'd be like right now who
name it like the patriots or the
warriors
the rams or anyone else so we had
10 15 different companies
10 15 000 each we split it all up and
that just started to come pretty
regularly
those investments and relationships were
critical of steve's own transition into
the world of investing but access to
money and deals while playing isn't a
guarantee of financial success well into
private equity was a windy road when
you're playing you're one of the best in
the world or best athletes in the world
but you don't have financial literacy
right
but you have all this money yeah
and so there's a big huge chasm in
between your financial literacy and the
money that's in the bank we've watched
those stories and the tragic stories it
was a painful moment
because when you have a somebody coming
and trying to take your rose bowl rings
your trophies your cars your house
redskins running back clinton portis
earning more than 40 million dollars on
the gridiron but life after football led
to bankruptcy and almost drove him to
murder
around 15
of nfl players file for bankruptcy
within 25 years of retirement
and while there are extreme examples of
failure and success
every player has the same transition
for me it started when i first got here
in 93 because i wasn't drafted so
being you know kind of coming in it was
like every day could be my last day
while junior bryant played for 10
seasons in the nfl his transition was
sudden while making a tackle junior went
airborne landing with his full weight on
his head
most careers kind of end like mine
unfortunately it's just the nature of
the game and even though i was doing all
that work from the very first day i
still wasn't ready i kind of really
wandered for a few years i had ideas of
things i wanted to do and but i just
didn't take the step just to kind of
move forward i had the same paralysis
like what what exactly am i gonna do
what am i even qualified to do
junior would eventually end up working
at hggc with steve as well as serve on
the board for his foundation forever
young through his foundation forever
young steve is looking to bridge that
gap between athletes having a lot of
money and as he describes financial
literacy he hopes to create a repository
of player transition stories
it's a resource for players by players
to give unbiased advice on what comes
after sports an effort to pay forward
his success off the field and help
others transition from the field to
executive suites like the one his firm
has at levi's stadium right so this is
the suite this is the firm suite the
suite
playing the game and what we all been
through players don't realize how useful
that can be if you paid attention they
don't realize the resource that they can
be as junior said we're all kind of
frozen and i want them to know by
definition of what you've been through
you have something to add to the
conversation
i began preparing for my future beyond
football probably earlier than i wanted
to because my dad kept packing at me
about the rest of my life what are you
gonna do what's your plan what's your
plan what's your plan and i was like my
plan is to play football he's like
that's not a plan
that motivation pushed steve to go back
to school at the same time he was
playing running from super bowls to law
school for six years
in 1994 the same year he was league mvp
he also graduated with a law degree from
brigham young
without the law degree i wouldn't have
been able to get the opportunity to get
into direct investing now did i have the
mba that everyone had out of harvard did
i do the four years of consulting or
banking no
but i think i was given the opportunity
because i had that in my pocket i
wouldn't have gone to law school if my
dad had not had driven in my head that
you better have a plan
as his professional career wound down he
would use those relationships forged in
the locker room to find ways into the
world of business he sat on the board of
power bar after becoming a huge fan of
the product as a player he used to just
down them on the sidelines
like niners teammates ronnie lott and
harris barton young had become more
invested in investing
he initially formed northgate capital
with some ex-teammates and then went on
to sorensen capital where he first
worked with his future partner rich
lawson
i actually started my career at morgan
stanley uh prior to business school in
the mergers and acquisitions department
uh and slept under a desk in new york
and in tokyo japan for morgan stanley we
started as direct investors at a firm
called sorenson capital and that was
probably 20 years ago
the two eventually decided to create
their own firm alongside two
high-caliber private equity mentors bob
gay and jon huntsman senior
what looked like a winning partnership
among the four of them initially called
huntsman gay global capital didn't last
gay opted to take a job with the mormon
church and huntsman who planned to join
after his company was bought never
joined when that deal to sell his
company fell through so no huntsman no
gay but young and lawson opted to press
ahead as hggc
so this is uh
it's the inner sanctum
i like it we did not clean it up for you
oh man
i apologize this is a working day
it's great and i do i love the helmet
the firm's offices are filled with
sports memorabilia much of which is used
for prizes and charity work that steve
and the firm participate in year-round
but steve is quick to point out that it
took a while for him to embrace being
surrounded by his past when i retired
from football roger staubach was my hero
and we developed a relationship and i
asked him roger
you're one of the greatest transition
guys in history of the nfl to go do
something else give me some tips and his
number one tip was run
and i go wrong what do you mean run he
goes just get it run away yeah and but
he said because it'll never leave you
you always have football in the history
of the nfl and all the things that
happened but you need to run
you also
and i don't think this is a stretch had
some
hesitation
about being
ex-football player
investor you wanted to be an investor is
that fair that's very fair and i think
the more famous you are as a player the
more accomplished you are the more i
thought the difficulty would to actually
have people take you seriously and i
wanted my fame to be a tool i didn't
want it to be a weapon and it's so easy
to weaponize right you can bring in and
just slay the room and that's not the
way i wanted to do it but certainly when
i started
i held myself back in some ways so
integral to that
transition as it were in that evolution
is rich lawson your partner and and we
actually i talked to him last week about
this very topic so i want to show you
something um all right his take on it
bring some drama
we have a very long hallway leading to
our shared office
that i can't seem to get my own wall uh
and so every week i would put up his
jerseys from his various different
accolades the usfl or the 49ers or byu
and it would be strange because one day
they'd be there and then i would come
back from a trip and they'd all be gone
so i think for years he wanted to
minimize what his pass was as opposed to
embrace it
it's been really critical to our
business it's given us a bit of a
defining characteristic in addition to
being good investors because no matter
how successful you are in other venues
if you're not delivering great returns
for your investors it doesn't matter
that's great
all true
every bit of it i'll call it immaturity
on my on my part but it was born out of
this desire to try to make sure that
what i was doing i wanted people to know
i was serious about
and that meant grinding it out on deals
doing the work to find buy and fix
companies hggc has completed more than
500 portfolio investments transactions
with an enterprise value of nearly 50
billion dollars young and lawson's
playbook
it's one of cultivating relationships
over long periods to consummate deals
as time went on the sports memorabilia
and wall street deal toys those lucite
mementos of companies bought sold or
taken public began to share space
you can see the fortnite room is the
main conference room okay we get it
someone joked i said we promised to put
you over joe it's the only place i ever
get
it's funny when i was
sneaking around your office earlier i
saw that picture of you
and montana very intimate portrait
we all agree that it was awkward yeah
and never wasn't awkward in fact the att
did a commercial on it recently
but but it was always profitable yeah
and i think that was the creative
tension that it would that had a part of
it and i'll always honor
my time with joe i hated watching
but i loved watching joe
do you think about that in the context
of
like business and ceos and succession
like oh honey you've got to right so
much of this business is classic
relationship
a few days later i joined steve at his
charity golf tournament at true north
just outside of scottsdale arizona the
proceeds of that day go to his
philanthropic organization forever young
for nearly three decades that's served
children facing significant physical
emotional and financial challenges i
love golf i love thinking about it i
just don't play it very often but i
believe that if you love golf and you
don't play very often you can get better
kind of in your backyard that's my
theory and it has proven untrue
[Music]
steve's ability on the course may not be
etched into any record books but
following him around it's clear that
it's not for lack of trying
oh well
all right
off we go we were constantly hustling
behind him as he caught up with
executives in the portfolio companies
and reminisce with former and current
players he was a day trader he caught
himself self self-made dedicated and so
he's on the bus after a game in new
england and he's day trading on the bus
and bill belichick sees him and cuts
them on the spot the season that they
went to the super bowl day trading got
them
in many ways it's a convention right of
the people that i don't see maybe once a
year we're half the field or more from
our own portfolio in our own firm and so
it's kind of all come together my firm
our charity our fundraising efforts and
then the friends that are around my dad
and my brother it's all happens right
there as a confluence of all these parts
of my life that have found its common
center you should meet andy this is andy
in the bright hat here he's a ceo it may
sound right but these personal
relationships and conversations that
steve has with folks on the golf course
it's actually similar to his and the
firm's approach to private equity for
them the art is in the relationships
built across the negotiating table and
even in the days months decades leading
up to being at that table rather than
excel-based financial models ground out
by young analysts in manhattan
skyscrapers more typically associated
with buyout firms if you
could leave the hubris behind but that
says
i love that business but it would be so
much better if i ran it
right to me the more profitable way to
do it
not just in returns but in kind of
legacy
in
abundance is to approach it kind of
looking at the person across the table
as your
strategic partner help me understand how
you fit into the family one of hggc's
best partnerships was with brian adams
the founder and ceo of an insurance
technology company called integrity
so we had an advisor
that
linked us up in the beginning and you
know the first thing
everybody thinks of steve as a football
player and you're intimidated by this
idea of this hall of fame quarterback
but what you really see quickly is how
humble steve is how normal he is
integrity was part of an auction in 2016
one where 19 others were bidding and
while hggc didn't put up the highest
monetary offer
it was the relationship that steve had
struck up with brian that helped them
win the deal
steve and i got to know each other and
got to become friends um and we started
really kind of aligning our values for
us it was a lot of this kind of value
alignment
it was like we've got to figure out how
to become partners um and and it's been
an incredible ride for us
after hggc took a minority stake in
integrity steve was appointed chairman
of the board in six years the company
grew from a few hundred employees to
more than five thousand that's in large
part due to acquiring 125 companies
through m a
most recently integrity got a new round
of funding 1.2 billion dollars from
silver lake one of the biggest firms out
there
they returned the fund and more
with one just one investment off of
a faith and a relationship really more
than anything and a belief in each other
integrity is also an interesting example
of something
notable and again somewhat radical that
you do around compensation and ownership
and something that you've extended that
idea even into your
own firm in it in a different way so
let's walk me through that brian had the
idea
that he had 3 000 employees at the time
and you know what the equity owners of
the business
the people that have the stock
are making incredible amounts of money
but the employees are getting paid their
salaries
what if we gave them
stock
in 2019 integrity would do something
almost unheard of for a company of their
size and potential they distributed
partial ownership in the company to
their employee base
he did that as a private business
and i thought that's a way to solve for
a lot of the ills of a corporate
world and how people see the world
as building equity inside the employee
base and i love that and i think we've
done in our firm as well and kind of
more distributed partnership and trying
to give equity out
ownership not just held by two people
because what that does is it allows for
generational
mindset steve's work with growing
players into business people mirrors the
work he's doing at his own firm
there he and lawson are nurturing the
next generation of investors at hggc
and they're thinking of how his legacy
will live on in the world of private
equity through those younger executives
this is a place where there are 25-ish
investment professionals and every
single one of us is welcome to bring our
ideas to the table and those ideas are
heard so we meet every friday for
investment committee and it's not just
the investment committee it's not the
five or ten partners that meet it's the
entire firm
and a lot of places that's not the case
a good friend ran a
famous private equity firm nearby and he
said your culture is what i want our
firm to be like what do you do i said
well the first thing you ought to do is
your founders need to
put all of their relationships in the
middle and no one owns anything
and you don't fight over those
relationships they're they're the firms
like 15 seconds he's like
yeah that's not gonna work it's like uh
i'm out i'm out so it's like the culture
has to be kind of in the roots
and that resonates with people
passing down this spirit of abundance
approach to private equity all came from
steve's playing days and his hall of
fame coach bill walsh
i watched him do it in the late 80s
there's a guy with a camera the old
school you know big thing
on his back and he'd follow bill around
everywhere filming bills he spoke to the
team went out on the practice field
installed the offense in the lunchroom
and i kept asking
what is this like a museum they're doing
or what are they doing a special
documentary like no one knew
well what it was was he was creating a
physical toolkit a video based
audio based of all his speeches and all
of his playbooks and all of his
installations everything paper-based
that he had and essentially wrapping it
all up as a toolkit to hand it
to his assistant coaches that he wanted
to go have success in the league
who takes all their secrets
all the things that makes them great at
the height of their greatness three or
four generations ahead of everybody else
in the league and wraps it up and hands
it
to the people who are leaving the to go
coach other places and then says to them
you know what i'll see in the
championship game and it happened
there's a spirit
to legacy there's a spirit too and so i
watched it and i said to him bill
why would you do that
he said steve we've got to give
opportunity i want these men to succeed
and i thought that's a heck of a
statement because of course you do but
who does the actual work to give them
the opportunity to go succeed and giving
away what you own that is most valuable
is that great business they would love
that
you can make an argument maybe that is
the great business that we need to be
[Music]
you